[Musique]
dames francophonie regroupe l'ensemble
des personnes et des pays qui utilisent
le français comme langue officielle et
qui pratique le français aujourd'hui on
estime à environ 300 millions de
locuteurs dans le monde même si on voit
bien que avec le temps les locuteurs
font de plus en plus nombreux notamment
en afrique si on veut réellement que le
français soit utilisé dans le monde il
faut accompagner à la fois le
développement de ces pays il faut donc
développer les outils de pédagogique la
capacité finalement à pratiquer la
langue française retrouve finalement la
francophonie dans beaucoup
d'organisation que ce soit des
organisations internationales géante
être naturellement l'organisation
internationale de la francophonie mais
également on retrouve l'utilisation du
français dans beaucoup d'institutions
comme par les jeux olympiques donc c'est
une des deux langues officielles on voit
bien que le français est pratiquée que
ce soit à l'onu au conseil de l'europe
on retrouve le français dont beaucoup
d'institutions internationales alors
l'assemblée parlementaire de la
francophonie par définition regroupe les
parlements qui ont d'abord qui ont voulu
être adhérents qui pratiquent le
français aujourd'hui 88 pays
88 assemblée parlementaire ou
institutions parlementaires se composent
l'assemblée parlementaire de la
francophonie cenal est très actif en
matériaux locaux phonie déjà au sein de
ces commissions permanentes il faut
savoir qu'à la fois et bien on parle
beaucoup de francophonie au sein de la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense et des forces armées et très
naturellement au sein de la commission
des affaires culturelles d'ailleurs un
groupe de travail spécifique concernant
la francophonie été créés dans cette
commission est donc ce groupe rencontre
beaucoup d'experts pratique des
auditions rédige des rapports avec des
propositions intéressantes j'ai en tête
notamment la proposition de la création
d'un erasmus de la francophonie on a une
présentation aussi de deux pièces
importantes d'ouvragés de lettres qui
sont aujourd'hui au sénat le premier
document que je vous présente c'est une
lettre de léopold sédar senghor qui est
une lettre de démission et donc c'est
cette lettre d'origine où il fait part
de sa volonté de cesser ses activités au
sénat puisqu'il va se concentrer à la
présidence
de la république du sénégal et donc
voilà c'est un document historique on
retrouve à la fois sa signature mais
également
l'enveloppent qui a servi à l'époque
donc enveloppe que clip destiné à gaston
monnerville à l'époque président